The move you're about to see was first
developed by my great great great
grandfather, Ross von Dunfee.
But really, it's as old as man's quest
to fly.
It's just a flip with a twist, right?
There's a lot more going on, but you
won't be able to absorb it the first
time you see it. Hi, savvy guy.
No Good. Okay.
Oh, you were right. I totally missed it.
I'm glad.
That happened. I'm actually glad that
happened. It's a good reminder that
Dunphy Tuck demands respect.
This time, for real?
Damn. Okay. That hurts.
Just adjust these springs.
They feel fine to me.
I'm sure they do. You don't have the
foot sensitivity of a tramp, champ.
If I ever had to read braille, I'd--
Oh, my God. I think I did it.
Did I do it? Almost.
Yeah. Your form is a little off.
Really? It felt perfect.
I'll try one more time.
I'm not sure that's such a good idea.
You might cement in some bad habits.
I did it again.
I'm going to get you some water.
You seem lightheaded and delusional
again.
Oh, honey, you look exhausted.
Well, I am not.
I am as strong as ever.
Certainly the strongest person in the
house.
Is Luke doing the Dunphy tuck?
Sort of a poor man's version of it.
Wow. He added a whole new twist.
It's called over rotation.
Look into it.
I was so caught up in my spring
cleaning, it took me a while to see
that Phil was feeling inadequate.
I knew what I needed to do.
When you guys are done out there.
Do you think you could give Luke my
list? I have some chores on here that
require some muscle.
Maybe I should take care of that.
No, no, no.
I can handle it.
Looks pretty busy out there, not
pointing his toes.
What are you doing?
Last item on the list.
Move the table.
No, you should not be doing that alone.
Really?
Because I got the fridge out to the
curb. How drug it Stand back.
I'm turtling her. No, you're going to.
Get hurt, sweetie. Let me get Luke.
Luke, No, no, no, no, no. I don't need
his help. Let him play his precious
banjo. It's like the banjo was mocking
me. You are not the man you used to be.
You get up four times at night to pee,
but to do your super duper old now.
Hey, take five.
I don't know that one.
Give me a couple of minutes. I'll
figure it out.
It's a little hard to get things done
with all the noise.
What's that?
Nothing. Is that a bra?
You're not supposed to have girls up
here.
I can explain.
You don't have to.
You think you're an adult, but you're
not. You're a kid living under my roof
and you have to obey my rules.
Oh, the G string snapped.
Probably not the first time that's
happened in here.
No, it hit my eye.
Is it bleeding?
First of all, eyes can't bleed.
So. Sammy Davis Jr.
That's bad. So the doctor will see you
in a few minutes. Nice,
someone can see.
Glad to know your good eye can still
roll. So still angry.
Oh.
Gee, why would I be angry?
Because you insulted me, maimed me and
belittled my achievements in the band.
Johnny and Trampoline Arts.
I'm sorry. I'm not proud of my behavior
today. Probably started with the 5K I
ran yesterday.
Ten K. For,
everyone else.
It's the first time in 15 years I
couldn't finish.
And today it's everything I can do.
You can do better. No, I can't.
Yes, you can.
It's okay. It's not your fault.
Every dad goes through it.
The day you start seeing his son as a
man and not a boy.
It's a shock.
Like when we first got high def TV and
I realized that Bradley had an earring.
I'm not as much of a man as you think,
Dad.
Oh, really? How come?
An hour ago, I had a 16 year old girl's
bra in my hand.
Can we talk somewhere more private?
The bra belongs to me.
Oh.
Okay. That's not the conversation I
thought we'd be having. But if that's
what you need on the outside to feel
like the Luke you are on the inside.
No, it's to practice on.
I stink at unhooking them.
Last week I tried to take one off.
A girl at a party.
I fumbled for so long she started to
laugh. It still haunts me.
That's why it didn't go away this week.
My trip wasn't canceled.
Everyone found out.
I get it. You couldn't face him.
Listen, I know this part of your life
may not be moving fast enough for you,
but enjoy it while it lasts.
Someday your life's going to be moving
faster than you want. And you can wind
up doing something dumb like blinding
your son.
I'm blind.
Probably not.
Luke Dunphy.
I know I'm getting a little old for this
place, but I do like coming here.
Oh, Lukey, you hurt your eye.
Do you need a hug?
A big one.
Come here.